pour faire cette oeuvre le chef de
cabinet et son équipe construisent le
déplacement se déplacent préalablement à
la visite du président de la république
sur les lieux du déplacement pour ériger
un programme pour vérifier que les
conditions du déplacement sont réalisés
il le fait en travaillant avec de
nombreux services
j'ai déjà parlé des acteurs locaux mais
de nombreux services au sein de l'elysée
des services qui sont en charge de la
construction matériel du déplacement
services audiovisuels l'intendance les
services qui sont en charge de la presse
et des services qui sont en charge de la
sécurité parmi lesquels le gspr ou
parfois plus rarement le commandement
militaire
le jour du déplacement le rôle du chef
de cabinet ou de ses adjoints et d'être
aux côtés du président de la république
pour guider le président de la
république dans son déplacement et le
cas échéant si cela est nécessaire
adapter le programme de son déplacement
donc il ne faut pas être étonné de voir
le chef de cabinet ou ses adjoints à
proximité du président de la république
parfois une grande proximité puisque
nous avons comme je le disais à orienter
ce déplacement il ressort de cette brève
présentation et je pourrais la
développer si vous le souhaitez que mes
missions en tant que chef de cabinet
mais c'est également celle de mes
adjoints sont celles d'un chef
d'orchestre des services de l'elysée une
expression qui a utilisé qui a été
utilisée je crois par le chef du gspr
chef d'orchestre des services à la fois
pour l'agenda et pour les déplacements
cette mission de déplacement aller
extrêmement prenante puisque un chef de
cabinet ou ses adjoints se déplacent
plusieurs jours par semaine en province
pour préparer ou réaliser ses
déplacements c'est pour répondre à ses
missions qu'à mon arrivée à l'elysée le
19 mai 2010 est en tant que chef de
cabinet j'ai constitué une structure à
mes côtés une structure rapprochée qui
chapeaute les services de l'elysée
structure qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon c'est pas très joli mais c'est
ainsi chaufferie de cabinet qui est
composée d'un chef de cabine et moi-même
d'un adjoint chef de cabinet adjoint et
j'insiste sur les maux qui est un sous
préfet et de deux chargés de mission
une sous préfète et un autre chargé de
mission et qui était monsieur alexandre
béland ex andreu benalla que j'ai donc
recruté en arrivant à l'elysée
concernant les faits qui se sont
déroulés le 1er mai et qui sont plus
spécifiquement l'objet de cette
commission denquête je dois vous dire
que le 29 avril de cette année j'ai pris
l'avion pour la nouvelle calédonie j'y
suis arrivé le 30 avril
n'ignorez pas que pour aller en nouvelle
calédonie à peu près 18 heures d'avion
le mardi 1er mai j'étais en seconde
mission préparatoire en nouvelle
calédonie il se trouve que c'est un
déplacement qui était particulièrement
complexe à organiser je vous ferai pas
l'affront de vous expliquer pourquoi
et notamment parce que pour la première
fois de notre histoire un président de
la république allait poser le pied a
ouvert j'étais avec le haut commissaire
pour terminer l'organisation de ce
déplacement extrêmement sensible du
président de la république président de
la république lui-même est arrivée sur
le territoire le jeudi 3 mai en fin
d'après-midi heure locale vers 17h après
deux jours passés en déplacement
international en australie ou
l'accompagner un chargé de mission de la
chefferie du cabinet la chargée de
mission de la chaufferie de cabine pour
ma part j'ai appris le jeudi 3 mai 3
mais un peu après 17 heures heure locale
soit 8 heures heure métropolitaine
les faits sur lesquels vous interroger
et l'intervention monsieur benalla lors
de la manifestation du 1er mai
je l'ait été par un contact avec mon
directeur de cabinet patrick strzoda
contact de routine
il est de bon usage lorsque le président
de la république arrive quelque part de
confirmer au directeur de cabinet que le
déplacement va se réaliser dans de
bonnes conditions j'ai donc appelé
patrick strzoda qui m'a informée des
faits que vous connaissez ce contact
gelé eu vers 21h très simplement j'ai
attendu d'être à la résidence du haut
commissaire pour le contacter il était
donc 12 heures à l'heure métropolitaine
monsieur strzoda m'a informé de ces
faits et il m'a immédiatement informé
également de la sanction qui a été prise
sanction qui je le dis fortement
traduisait la volonté qui était la
sienne je crois qu'ils voulaient a
expliqué de prendre au plus vite une
mesure à l'encontre de monsieur benalla
condamnons ces agissements et ceci
évidemment sans attendre le retour en
métropole du chef de cabinet et du
président de la république